WE WILL SEE YOU BACK HERE
TOMORROW.
BE WELL.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
FOR THE PAST WEEK, ALL OF US
HAVE SEEN CHAOS ENGULF OUR
BELOVED COUNTRY.
THE VIOLENCE AT THE DESTRUCTION
HAS BEEN SO OVERWHELMING,
SHOCKING, AND AWFUL, AND VIVID
THAT IT HAS BEEN HARD TO THINK
CLEARLY ABOUT WHAT’S GOING ON. H
STEP BACK FAR ENOUGH TO ASK EVEN
THE OBVIOUS QUESTION.
THE MOST OBVIOUS OF COURSE IS
WHAT IS THIS REALLY ABOUT?
WHAT DO THE MOBS WANT?
THEY CAN’T ANSWER THAT QUESTION,
THEY HAVE NO IDEA, THEY JUST
WANT FREE iPADS.
BUT WHAT ABOUT APPLE ITSELF AND
THE REST OF CORPORATE AMERICA
WHICH IS ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SUPPORTING THE RIOTS?
WHAT ABOUT MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
THE MEDIA FIGURES, THE CELEBRITY
CELEBRITY, WHAT DO THEY WANT OUT
OF IT?
THAT’S THE CENTRAL MYSTERY.
NOW SUDDENLY, IT IS OBVIOUS.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN OBVIOUS THE
FIRST DAY.
THIS IS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
OF COURSE IT IS.
WE JUST COULDN’T SEE IT.
FOR NORMAL PEOPLE, DONALD TRUMP
IS A PRESIDENT.
YOU MAY LIKE HIM, YOU MAY NOT
LIKE HIM, BUT EITHER WAY, THEY
WILL BE ANOTHER PRESIDENT AT
SOME POINT AND WE WILL MOVE ON
AS WE ALWAYS HAVE.
FOR DONALD TRUMP’S ENEMIES,
THERE IS NOTHING ELSE.
EVERYTHING IS ABOUT TRUMP,
EVERYTHING.
DONALD TRUMP DEFINES HER
FRIENDSHIPS, THEIR CAREERS,
THEIR MARRIAGES.
DONALD TRUMP AFFECTS HOW THEY
RAISE THEIR CHILDREN.
DONALD TRUMP OCCUPIES THE VERY
CENTER OF THEIR LIVES.
AS LONG AS HE REMAINS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, THEY FEEL POWERLESS
AND DIMINISHED AND PANICKED THEY
CANNOT BE HAPPY.
AND EVERYTHING THEY DO, THEIR
OVERRIDING GOAL IS TO REMOVE
DONALD TRUMP FROM OFFICE.
AND THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT THEY’RE
TRYING TO DO NOW.
THAT’S WHAT THESE RIOTS ARE
ABOUT.
THE MOST PRIVILEGED IN OUR
SOCIETY ARE USING THE MOST
DESPERATE IN OUR SOCIETY TO
SEIZE POWER FROM EVERYONE ELSE.
GOT THAT?
THAT’S THE SOME OF IT.
THE MOST PRIVILEGED ARE USING
THE MOST DESPERATE TO SEIZE
POWER FROM THE REST OF US.
THEY ARE NOT SEEKING RACIAL
JUSTICE.
THEY WERE SEEKING RACIAL
JUSTICE, THEY WOULDN’T BE
DENOUNCING THEIR FELLOW
AMERICANS.
WHAT THEY ARE SEEKING IS TOTAL
CONTROL OF THE COUNTRY.
AND IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT
NONE OF THIS HAS ANYTHING TO DO
WITH GEORGE FLOYD.
SHAME ON THOSE WHO PRETEND THAT
IT DID, THOSE WHO FELL FOR THE
LIE, AND THOSE WHO KNEW BETTER
BUT PLAYED ALONG BECAUSE THEY
ARE COWARDS.
THERE WERE MANY OF THOSE.
YOU KNOW WHO THEY ARE, AND
SOMEDAY, WE WILL LOOK BACK AT
ALL OF THEM WITH CONTEMPT.
MEANWHILE, THE MANY PROMOTERS OF
THIS CHAOS REMAIN CLEAR.
THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT’S GOING
ON, AND THEY KNOW WHAT THEY HOPE
TO ACHIEVE BY IT.
WITH EVERY NIGHT OF RIOTING,
THEY GROW BOLDER.
NOW THEY ARE OPENLY DEFENDING
VIOLENCE ON TELEVISION.
>> PEOPLE WORRY ABOUT THE
PROTESTERS AND THE LOOTERS, AND
IS JUST PEOPLE WHO WERE
FRUSTRATED.
>> THEY ARE FRUSTRATED AND THEY
ARE ANGRY AND THEY ARE OUT THERE
AND THEY ARE UPSET.
SHOULDN’T BE TAKING TELEVISIONS,
BUT I CAN’T TELL PEOPLE HOW TO
REACT TO THIS.
>> I’M PROUD OF THE PROTESTS AND
I THINK IT’S PART OF THE
TRADITION OF NEW YORK.
THE VIOLENCE IS BAD,
REPREHENSIBLE, BUT IT IS NOT THE
OVERWHELMING PICTURE IN
NEW YORK.
>> DESTROYING PROPERTY WHICH CAN
BE REPLACED IS NOT VIOLENCE.
>> MANY SEE THE PROTESTS AS THE
PROBLEM.
PLEASE SHOW ME WHERE IT SAYS
PROTESTS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
POLITE AND PEACEFUL.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE CRUSHED BY
THIS, YOU CAN’T BELIEVE IT’S
HAPPENING TO YOUR COUNTRY, BUT
FOR THE PEOPLE YOU JUST SAW, THE
REAL PROBLEM IS THAT THE RIOTING
IN SOME RARE PLACES IS BEING
STOPPED BY POLICE, AND THEIR AIM
IS TO FIX THAT.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO ELIMINATE ALL
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR GOOD.
TODAY, DEMOCRATS IN DALLAS TOOK
DOWN THE STATUE OF A TEXAS
RANGER FROM THE TERMINAL AND
STOOD IN THE AIRPORT FOR MORE
THAN 50 YEARS.
THE TEXAS RANGERS ARE COPS AND
COPS MUST BE REMOVED EVEN WHEN
THEY ARE MADE OF BRONZE.
MEANWHILE, THE LEGO TOY COMPANY
HAS SEIZED MARKETING SETS THAT
CONTAIN PLASTIC POLICE OFFICERS.
APPARENTLY TOO DANGEROUS FOR OUR
CHILDREN.
SO MUCH OF THIS GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
IT ALL SEEMS LIKE ANOTHER
EPISODE OF THIS HYSTERIA THAT
GROUPS OUR CULTURE OUT OF
NOWHERE, YOU SHOULD KNOW IT IS
NOT THAT.
THIS IS ENTIRELY REAL, IT IS
BEING PUSHED BY SERIOUS PEOPLE,
AND THEY ARE DEADLY SERIOUS
ABOUT IT.
LAST NIGHT, THE PRESS SECRETARY
OF THE HILLARY CLINTON FOR
PRESIDENT CAMPAIGN IN THE LAST
ELECTION CYCLE THAT WE DID
"DEFUND THE POLICE."
CONGRESSWOMAN RASHIDA TLAIB
AGREES EXPECTING MORE SOON.
IN SOME PLACES, THEY ARE NOT
TALKING OR ACTING.
STEVE FLETCHER REPRESENTS THE
THIRD WARD IN MINNEAPOLIS.
BY THIS WEEK, HIS CITY HAD BEEN
COMPLETELY SCORCHED BY RIOTS, AT
LEAST 66 BUSINESSES WERE UTTERLY
DESTROYED BY FIRE.
AT THREE MORE VANDALIZED OR
DILUTED.
DOESN’T EVEN MENTION THAT.
INSTEAD, HE ATTACKED THE CITY’S
POLICE DEPARTMENT FOR TRYING TO
CONTAIN THE VIOLENCE.
"SEVERAL OF US ON THE COUNSELOR
WORKING OUT WHAT IT WOULD TAKE
TO DISBAND THE MINNEAPOLIS
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
YOU THINK PEOPLE IN THE CITY
WOULD BE SHOCKED BY THAT BUT
EVERYONE ELSE NODDED THEIR
APPROVAL.
WE DID THIS YESTERDAY, "THE
MINNEAPOLIS POLICE DEPARTMENT IS
NOT REFORM A REFORM A BOWL.
COMING.
ACCORDING TO THE CITY COUNCIL
AND FLETCHER, ALL NINE MEMBERS
OF THE CITY COUNCIL ARE NOW
CONSIDERING GETTING RID OF THE
MINNEAPOLIS POLICE DEPARTMENT.
HARD TO BELIEVE, BUT NOT JUST
THERE.
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES,
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI LOOKS OUT
ACROSS THE WORST RIOTING IN THE
NATION’S SECOND LARGEST CITY IN
A GENERATION, AND ALMOST 30
YEARS AND HIS CONCLUSION?
WE NEED FAR FEWER POLICE.
COULD HAVE BEEN BETTER IF THEY
HADN’T BEEN THERE.
HE HAS ANNOUNCED HE’S GOING TO
CUT FUNDING FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> I WANT YOU TO KNOW WE WILL
NOT BE INCREASING OUR POLICE
BUDGET.
HOW CAN WE AT THIS MOMENT?
OUR CITY THROUGH OUR CITY
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER
IDENTIFIED $250 MILLION IN CUTS
SO WE COULD INVEST IN JOBS AND
HEALTH AND EDUCATION AND
HEALING.
FOUND THAT THOSE DOLLARS NEED TO
BE FOCUSED ON OUR BLACK
COMMUNITY HERE IN LOS ANGELES.
AS WELL AS COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND WOMEN AND PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN LEFT BEHIND FOR TOO LONG.
WILL THIS INVOLVE CUTS?
YES, OF COURSE, TO EVERY
DEPARTMENT INCLUDING THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> Tucker: WHEN DEMOCRATS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY START SAYING
THE SAME THING AT THE SAME TIME,
YOU CAN BE CERTAIN THERE’S A
REASON FOR IT.
IN THIS CASE, THEY CLEARLY MEAN
IT.
ACCORDING TO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE L.A. POLICE COMMISSION, CITY
OFFICIALS MAKE UP $150 MILLION
FROM THE L.A.P.D.
MORE THAN 10% OF THE ENTIRE
POLICE BUDGET IN THE WAKE OF
RIOTING.
IN NEW YORK, 48 SEPARATE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES SIGNED A
LETTER DEMANDING A $1 BILLION
CUT TO THE BUDGET OF THE NYPD.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
THERE ARE REASONS, NOT THE ONES
THEY TELL YOU.
THEY TELL YOU IT’S ABOUT RACISM
AND THAT COPS ARE RACIST AND
MUST BE REINED IN.
MOST AMERICANS DON’T AGREE WITH
THAT.
THAT’S NOT THE EXPERIENCE THEY
HAVE.
IN FACT, POLICE DEPARTMENTS ARE
ONE OF THE MOST TRUSTED
INSTITUTIONS IN THE COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO GALLUP POLLING LAST
YEAR, 53% OF AMERICANS SAID THEY
HAD QUITE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE IN
THE POLICE.
THAT WAS FAR MORE CONFIDENCE
THAN THEY HAD IN ALMOST ANY
OTHER INSTITUTION.
THANKS, RELIGIOUS LEADERS, THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM, TELEVISION
NEWS, PUBLIC SCHOOLS, CORPORATE
AMERICAN NEWSPAPERS, NAME ONE.
HOW MANY AMERICANS TRUSTED
CONGRESS?
11%.
AND IN FACT, MOST
AFRICAN-AMERICANS STILL SUPPORT
THE POLICE.
THE 2016 FOR FOUND THAT 15% OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS HAD CONFIDENCE
IN THE POLICE WITHIN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES.
IN OTHER WORDS, COPS THEY KNEW
AND DEALT WITH.
A STUDY BY THE BUREAU OF JUSTICE
STATISTICS IN 2011 FOUND THAT
AMONG THOSE WHO CALLED THE
POLICE FOR HELP, MORE THAN 90%
OF AFRICAN-AMERICANS FELT THE
POLICE BEHAVED PROPERLY.
SO WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF WE GOT
RID OF THE POLICE?
HOW WOULD AMERICANS FEEL IF THEY
ACTUALLY DEFUNDED THE POLICE?
TERRIFIED, MOSTLY.
THAT’S HOW WE WOULD FEEL.
THINGS WOULD FALL APART
INSTANTLY.
WOULD TAKE HOURS?
DON’T BELIEVE IT?
SPEND A FEW HOURS IN A PLACE
WITH NO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND SEE
WHAT YOU THINK.
TALK TO ANYONE WHO WAS IN
BAGHDAD AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
IRAQ WAR.
ASK ANYONE WHO STAYED IN
NEW ORLEANS.
THEY WILL NEVER FORGET WHAT THEY
SAW.
HERE’S THE KEY.
ELIMINATING THE POLICE DOES NOT
MEAN ELIMINATING AUTHORITY.
THERE WAS ALWAYS AUTHORITY.
THERE ARE NO VACUUMS IN NATURE.
THE ONLY QUESTION IS WHETHER OR
NOT THE AUTHORITY AS LEGITIMATE.
WHETHER OR NOT THE AUTHORITY IS
ACCOUNTABLE.
WHETHER OR NOT YOU CAN DO
ANYTHING IF THE AUTHORITY ABUSES
OF POWER.
IN THE ABSENCE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE ANSWER IS
NO.
IT MEANS THUGS ARE IN CHARGE.
THE MOST VIOLENT PEOPLE HAVE THE
MOST POWER.
THEY CAN DO WHATEVER THEY WANT
TO YOU.
THAT’S THE REALITY.
EVERYONE OBEYS THE VIOLENT
PEOPLE WHERE THEY GET HURT.
THE MOB LITERALLY RULES.
THAT PROBABLY SOUNDS LIKE A
NIGHTMARE TO YOU, BECAUSE IT IS.
BUT THE PEOPLE PUSHING THIS IDEA
DON’T SEE IT AS SCARY BECAUSE
THEY DON’T FEAR THE MOB BECAUSE
THEY CONTROL THE MOB.
THAT’S THE KEY, AND THEY SEE
VIOLENCE AS AN INSTRUMENT OF
THEIR POLITICAL POWER.
WITH MOBS IN THE STREETS THAT
THEY CONTROL, THEY WILL FINALLY
GET WHAT THEY WANT.